suppose we multiply a complex number z
by negative
3i and they show us z right over here
plot the point that represents the
product of z and
negative 3i so pause this video and see
if you can work through that
all right now let's do it step by step
first i want to think about
what would where would 3z be
well 3z would have the same angle
as z but its absolute value or its
modulus would be three times larger
so you'd be going in this direction but
it'd be three times further so that's
one times
its modulus that's two times its modulus
that's three times its modulus or it's
three times its absolute value
so 3z would be right over here
now what about negative 3z
well if you multiply it by a negative
it's just going to flip it around you
could think about it as flipping it at
180 degrees
but it's going to have the same modulus
so
instead of being right over here at 3 in
this direction it's going to be 1
2 3 in this direction right over here so
that is
negative 3 z and now perhaps
most interestingly what happens when you
multiply by
i so if we have negative 3i
times z now which is exactly what they
want us to figure out
well let's think about what happens if
you had 1 and if you multiplied it by i
so 1 times i becomes 1i so it goes over
there
what if you then took 1i and multiplied
it by i
well then you have negative 1. what if
you took negative 1 and you multiplied
it by i
well then now you have negative 1i
so notice every time we multiply by i we
are rotating by 90 degrees
so over here if we take negative 3z and
multiply it by
i you're just going to rotate 90 degrees
and you're going to get right over there
so this is negative
3i times z which is exactly what we were
looking for